[Música]
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump informó que fue acusado en medio
de una investigación por su manejo de
documentos clasificados Trump quien
enfrenta cargos por conspiración falso
testimonio entre otros aseguró que es
inocente
Cuba niega que haya pactado con China la
instalación de una gran base en la isla
para espiar a Estados Unidos tal como lo
reportó el periódico de Wall Street
journal el pentágono también desestimó
esta información y dijo que no estaba al
tanto del asunto
el fiscal general de la Corte Penal
Internacional llegó a Venezuela Karim se
reunió con el presidente Nicolás maduro
y otras autoridades del país en medio de
las investigaciones para determinar si
bajo esta administración se cometieron
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz damos inicio en
Estados Unidos porque a través de su red
social 3 social del expresidente Donald
Trump informó que fue acusado en medio
de la investigación por su manejo de
documentos clasificados El mandatario
señaló que el departamento de Justicia
le notificó la decisión al tiempo que se
declaró inocente los hechos tienen que
ver con los archivos clasificados
hallados El año pasado en su mansión de
mar al lago en Florida Trump enfrentará
al menos siete cargos entre los que se
encuentran espionaje conspiración y
falso testimonio
tristemente estamos en un país en
declive y aún así persiguen a un
presidente popular un presidente que ha
tenido más votos que ningún otro
presidente en ejercicio en la historia
de nuestro país por mucho Iván tras él
por el engaño de las cajas es como El
engaño Ruso y como todos los demás esto
ha pasado por siete años y no pueden
detenerse porque esta elección
interfiere en los más altos niveles
nunca ha ocurrido nada como esto soy un
hombre inocente el diario estadounidense
de Wall Street journal señaló que el
gobierno chino y el cubano habrían
firmado un acuerdo que le permitiría a
Beijing instalar una base que
funcionaría como centro de espionaje en
esa isla el informe fue desestimado por
los voceros del pentágono al tiempo que
la Habana negó categóricamente la
información
vestigios de la guerra fría con Cuba en
el centro de la polémica nuevamente a
flote de acuerdo con la publicación de
Wall Street journal que cita de manera
anónima a los funcionarios de
inteligencia estadounidenses china
habría alcanzado un acuerdo con Cuba
para instalar una base en la isla
caribeña a cambio del pago de millones
de dólares que le permitiría espiar a
los estadounidenses a 90 millas de las
cosas de Florida al sureste del país el
pentágono restó importancia a la
publicación calificándola como inexacta
puedo decirles con base a la información
que tenemos que eso no es Exacto que no
estamos al tanto de que China y Cuba
desarrolle en algún tipo de estación de
espionaje
Station el pacto permitiría Beijing
captar señales de inteligencia en partes
del sureste de Estados Unidos hogar de
instalaciones militares e importantes
industrias al tiempo que para Cuba Se
presenta como un bálsamo en medio de la
crisis económica que padece el gobierno
de La Isla rechazó el informe y acusó
que forma parte de un plan para
justificar el recrudecimiento del
embargo nuestro país es firmante de la
declaración de América Latina y del
Caribe como zona de paz suscrita en la
Habana en enero de 2014
en virtud de ella rechazamos toda
presencia militar foránea en América
Latina y el Caribe incluida la de
numerosas bases y efectivos militares de
los Estados Unidos la noticia tensa aún
más las relaciones entre Washington y la
Habana al tiempo que incrementa los
temores de un sector en Estados Unidos
por la expansión de china en América
Latina y el Caribe
Canadá enfrenta una de las peores rachas
de incendios forestales de su historia
desde hace semanas el fuego ha consumido
millones de hectáreas en todo el país y
el humo ha afectado la calidad del aire
en las principales ciudades que han
tenido que limitar algunas actividades
en el exterior solo en Quebec 13.500
personas han sido evacuadas
los cielos de la ciudad más poblada de
Canadá están cubiertos de neblina a
Toronto en el este del país llegó el
humo producido por los incendios
forestales de provincias del extremo
oeste como Alberta y Columbia británica
salgo a caminar todos los días por la
mañana y me doy cuenta que la calidad
del aire ha empeorado a 400 kilómetros
en la capital canadiense Ottawa el humo
también ha limitado algunas actividades
en el exterior el servicio meteorológico
nacional ubicó a la capital en la peor
clasificación de su escala de calidad
del Aire El Primer Ministro canadiense
Justin trudeo informó a la prensa que el
país enfrenta a una de las peores
temporadas de forestales de la historia
desde mayo los incendios han arrasado
más de 3 millones de hectáreas en casi
todas las 13 provincias y territorios de
Canadá de Costa a costa del fuego avanza
Quebec es la víctima más reciente con
cerca de 140 incendios activos en esta
provincia pueblos enteros han tenido que
ser evacuados mientras bomberos
canadienses y de varias nacionalidades
combaten las llamas
hay 414 incendios forestales Ardiendo
239 de los cuales están fuera de control
también a la fecha estimamos que veinte
mil ciento ochenta y tres personas
siguen evacuadas de sus hogares Y
comunidades
la situación podría empeorar en las
próximas semanas con el inicio del
fenómeno del niño los incendios causados
por altas temperaturas son el rostro el
cambio climático en el país
norteamericano
en la capital de la República Mexicana
cientos de personas marcharon desde el
Monumento a la independencia hasta el
Zócalo para solidarizarse con las
comunidades zapatistas de Chiapas que
han padecido un incremento de la
violencia y advierten que están al borde
de una guerra civil Mario carbonel
corresponsal en Ciudad de México estuvo
en la movilización y tiene los detalles
este 8 de junio es la fecha señalada por
el ejército zapatista de liberación
nacional el ezln para llevar a cabo esta
jornada global de protesta y exigir que
cese lo que ellos consideran es la
guerra contra las comunidades zapatistas
el pasado 22 de mayo de este año ocurrió
un ataque con armas de fuego en la
comunidad Moisés Gandhi que está en
ococingo Y en este ataque fue herido de
gravedad nuestro compañero Jorge López
santis el cual Pues sigue hospitalizado
y Bueno pues esta agresión se enmarca en
una serie de
de ataques violentos en contra de las
comunidades zapatistas que llevan ya
muchos años la última semana de mayo
pobladores del municipio de frontera
Comalapa vivieron días de terror la
violencia derivada de la disputa por el
territorio entre el cartel Jalisco Nueva
Generación del Cartel De Sinaloa provocó
balaceras amenazas y reclutamiento
forzado por ello cerca de 3000
habitantes se vieron obligados al
desplazamiento forzado vemos que el
crimen organizado y sus distintos
negocios trata de mujeres trata de
personas venta de drogas venta de armas
prostitución está ya penetrando las
comunidades indígenas un fenómeno que no
habíamos visto antes en el país la
situación en el estado es delicada el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
ha dicho que se han desplegado ya a
elementos de las fuerzas federales para
resguardar el orden pero que hay bases
social del crimen organizado dice que
hay pobladores que apoyan a los
criminales lo cierto que quienes están
padeciendo esta situación de violencia
son los niños las mujeres los adultos
mayores en las comunidades zapatistas
por esto Esta convocatoria apoyada por
personalidades como
Gael García el actor
buscan despertar la conciencia y dicen
que van a seguir defendiendo a las
comunidades zapatistas
[Música]
Chiapas aguanta el pueblo se levanta
vamos a Venezuela porque el fiscal de la
Corte Penal Internacional Karim hansen
reunió con el presidente Nicolás maduro
y con el fiscal general William saab
para evaluar la implementación de un
compromiso firmado entre el estado y la
cpi en 2021 el encuentro se produce
luego de que han solicitar en noviembre
pasado continuar con la investigación
sobre presuntos crímenes de lesa
humanidad en Venezuela que fue
suspendida a petición del gobierno de
Caracas Daniela Zambrano nuestra
corresponsal de France 24 en la capital
venezolana nos amplió los detalles
en su tercera visita a Venezuela el
fiscal de la Corte Penal Internacional
karincan se reunió con autoridades del
poder ejecutivo del poder judicial a fin
de avanzar en las investigaciones para
determinar si en Venezuela se cometieron
crímenes de lesa humanidad bajo la
administración de Nicolás maduro una
visita que no fue anunciada con
antelación y que en principio se manejó
con total hermetismo la fiscalía también
investiga si los tribunales en Venezuela
imparten justicia en los casos de
violaciones a derechos humanos que se
han denunciado recordemos que hace un
mes aproximadamente la fiscalía recibió
cerca de ocho mil novecientos
testimonios de personas que se
consideran Víctimas de abuso por parte
del Estado venezolano y aproximadamente
en marzo del año pasado el fiscal había
advertido que se abriría una oficina en
Venezuela para brindar asistencia
técnica a las autoridades en horas de la
noche el fiscal de la Corte Penal
Internacional también acudió al palacio
de Miraflores Allí se reunió con el
presidente Nicolás maduro y con la
primera dama Silvia flores al momento no
ha habido declaraciones a los medios de
comunicación y se desconoce si karinkan
se va a reunir con representantes de
organizaciones no gubernamentales y
asociaciones de víctimas algunas de
ellas se han pronunciado a través de
redes sociales Como por ejemplo provea
que han dicho que en Venezuela se
necesitan investigaciones genuinas y no
simulaciones de Justicia
hasta aquí este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]